hello everyone and welcome to the other
match of the semi-finals of the ancient
u.s rapid knockouts its father slovakia
vs alireza ferrugia and uh well it was
definitely quite a match if you remember
in the first match uh the the match
started by artemi winning and then two
games were drawn and then alireza
finally won in game four and uh drew the
match in the second match alireza
started by winning the second game and
then artem retaliated in the third game
with the fourth game ending in a draw so
both games both matches ended in a draw
and then of course they had to go in the
tie break so they played two blitz games
in the tie breaks uh and uh let me just
uh fix this because i realized i haven't
so two blitz games were played five plus
three and both blitz games ended in a
draw and now of course we are in
armageddon uh which means uh that white
gets uh five minutes on the clock black
has uh four minutes on the clock but
white has to win the game so if alireza
drews this draws this uh then the match
ends in a draw and i've seen in the
comments of the previous video a lot of
you were wondering what's uh you know
what's wrong with my voice i had my uh
15-year high school reunion yesterday so
you know i stayed up a bit late we had
some you know wine some beer some some
rakia and you know well
everything that
everything that follows uh so it took a
a toll it would seem on my voice a
little bit but i'm feeling a lot better
now and it should be completely restored
tomorrow uh so
just to update you guys on that now
getting back to the match uh artemiev
has the white pieces and he absolutely
must win this game if he wants to uh win
the match and face carlson in the finals
so let's check it out timmy with the
white pieces opens with d4 uh we have
knight to f6 and bishop to g5 for this
must-win game uh artemis chooses the
trompovsky attack we have d5 by alireza
and knight to d2 we have h6 now
challenging this bishop here and bishop
to h4
we have bishop to f5 and now e3 so
keeping everything very solid not
trading anything off the board you have
to keep your winning chances alive as
long as possible and of course you have
to play fast so e6 and now knight g to
f3 of course we have to continue
development bishop to e7 uh and now uh
there are a few games where bishop to e2
was played but here we have c for
bartimaev and it is already as of move
seven that we have a completely new game
so alireza castles here and the queen to
b3 now not putting pressure on d5 but
also attacking that b7 pawn but it's not
uh really free for grab cell it is it
just develops the knight and you can't
really go for the pawn if you capture it
now knight before and you will have a
lot of problems uh defending this
position with white so instead after
knight to c6 just bishop to e2 artemiev
also needs to finish development and now
knights to a5 attacking the queen
putting more pressure on c4 so queen to
a4 attacking the knight and here alireza
just captures this this is definitely uh
in his uh favor to to get some pieces
and pawns of the board we have knight
captures knight captures d captures
queen captures and now knight the e4
offering even more trades which is of
course good for him because if he can
get a draw in this game then he wins the
match so bishop captures any seven queen
captures and artemis now castles and now
uh what what's left to do is of course
c5 further attacking the center here and
alerissa can be very very happy with his
position uh we have rook f to d1 the
other rook is coming to c1 and uh
artemiev wants to finish development we
have c captures on d4 knight captures on
d4 attacking the bishop here and the
bishop back to g6 and now rook ate the
c1 and now all all of the pieces are
nicely placed and fully developed we
have rook f2d8 by alireza and now f3
kicking away the knight from this uh
very active square we have knight back
to d6 attacking the queen and just queen
b4 now pinning the knight the queen on
e7 is undefended and of course uh
alireza will have to figure out a way
out of this so queen to g5 now attacking
the e3 pawn for the moment it's
undefended uh but artemis just plays f4
so the queen goes back we have queen to
f6 and now knight to f3
and here the problem is it's not very
easy to get this rook into the game if
you just play rook a2c8 it seems like a
logical move uh it just loses the pawn
we're gonna capture here you can't
capture with the rook because the knight
falls so you have to capture with the
knight and then let's say captures
captures and now we pick up the base
seven pawn now and now it is free and
now white is just uh up up upon and well
he has two two one advantage on the
queen side he should have excellent
winning chances so after this knight to
f3 we have knights to f5 uh now again
putting pressure on the e3 pawn and the
king to f2 this is how artemiev defends
we have bishop to h5 now
threatening to trade down even further
and artemis plays g3 and uh there really
isn't a a good way for for white to try
and push for anything here uh but
alireza makes it possible so here what
you probably want to do is just trade
captures captures and push e5 and you
are you are just uh you know feeling
great here as black but for some reason
i don't know if it was uh some deep uh
miscalculation or maybe just uh you know
uh maybe he uh switched the move order
or something but instead of capturing
and then playing e5 alireza played e5
right away and although it looks like
there could be something going on here
there really isn't and it's just a just
a free pawn so well you could capture
with the knight it's not a problem just
knight captures on e5 there's really no
way for for black to do anything about
this artemia even captures with the pawn
he plays f characters on e5 and now
alireza plays queen to e6 and okay now
you've opened up the white king a little
bit but the problem is the position is
now uh completely winning for white so
feel free to pause the video here and
win the game for artemiev while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on realizing that the
queen is covering the g4 square and that
the g4 just wins the uh a piece here so
congratulations to everyone who found
this alireza somehow missed this and of
course artemis played it uh he was uh
down on the clock he he had a few
seconds on the clock whereas artemis had
over two minutes but still it's such a
such a rough blunder uh definitely not
not an easy one especially after two
days of such grueling matches against
artemis to you know go down like this uh
but okay there's nothing better all it
is a capture with the bishop queen
captures on g4 now uh all it is are
traded on d1 we have bishop captures on
d1 and now g6 kind of keeping the knight
safe now the queen can move uh but
adjust the bishop to b3 guarding the
pawn also pushing the queen away queen
to b6 and now queen to e4 now the idea
is e6 and there's really nothing black
can do about this rook to d8 was played
and now of course artemis continues
pushing forward we have e6 the bishop
wants to uh you know
open up the the this diagonal we have
king to f8 and now queen to e5 regarding
the c7 square uh artemis is preparing
rook to c7 which would cover the e7
square and then uh well just queen to h8
for example would be checkmate and there
is no good way to stop this already just
played pretty much any move he played a5
allowed rook to c7 and he was in this
position on move 32 that alireza ferruja
resigned the game as there is no defense
against the position from the thumbnail
or uh the checkmate on h8
uh so really a spectacular match uh
sorry like i said i was
i had my uh 15-year high school reunion
so i couldn't cover all of the games
yesterday but i decided to show this one
is it's uh well it's just a
very very tough loss for alireza but now
as you as you've seen it will be magnus
vs vladislav in the finals so we're
gonna have a lot of fun covering both of
the matches and we can only hope this
match as well goes to armageddon
so
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank aditya parasarati
christopher alexander sopa tom darrell
kickdefy.com and vincent natalie for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
finals uh and that's it uh thank you all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your weekend